all right President Trump led the bigger
fourth of July celebration he wanted but
did not get the weather he hoped for a
big crowd stood in the rain to hear him
pay tribute to US military power and see
a display of it along the National Mall
in Washington the speech was patriotic
but not political at least not
explicitly chip Reid is at the White
House chip how did the storm affect the
president's event well yes there was
drenching rain and part of the mall was
even evacuated temporarily because of
lightning but in the end the president
got his big celebration today we come
together as one nation with his very
special salute to America under gloomy
skies and following a downpour mr.
Trump's salute to America went on we
celebrate our history our people and the
heroes who proudly defend our flag with
the military's might front and center
each branch of the United States Armed
Forces the Army Navy Air Force Coast
Guard Marines and very soon the space
force 800 members of the DC National
Guard were dispatched nearly three times
the number compared to previous years
the military flyovers cost tens of
thousands of dollars per hour though the
events final cost is still unknown the
president abandoned his frequent attacks
on political opponents and instead
called for unity Americans always take
care of each other but the tribute to
the nation's birthday did not come
without protest
police arrested demonstrators burning
the flag outside the White House
[Music]
but despite the rain clouds and protests
the Capitals biggest fireworks display
like the President's speech went forward
the fireworks actually had to be moved
away from the reflecting pool and the
Lincoln Memorial area where they usually
are because of the president's address
and as for those tanks that were on
display well the DC government is
demanding that the federal government
reimburse them for any damage to roads
and bridges Gail right chip I kept
wondering why they didn't get somebody
to wipe off the glass while the
president was talking kept wondering
about that thank you very much sir